hello pollination my name is having
coverage of my laundry's believe and I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so
help fund your journey today I'm going
to talk about seven ways to write a book
for beginners so I was my third filled
with Indian Random House in December of
last year I'm in the process of writing
my second book and I have the first
draft just create a super sense of that
I've been getting a lot of questions
from you guys asking me about the
process how do I write a book what does
it look like how to make sure the high
focus is except coming out of the gate
and so today I want to share with you
seven ways and how to do is that I think
you'll enjoy tip number one actually
want to write a book this might sound
like a no-brainer but I think a lot of
people want to write a book for the
wrong reason a lot of people want to
write a book because the things are
going to get them credibility is going
to open up doors and it can and it does
I think it was a lot more true ten years
ago that it is now I can open up almost
any to our blog just using my youtube
channel or my social media much more
than the book helps me do that there
were does many happening is the word
before and so you needed to have a book
but now it's not as necessary I don't
always do it it's not important at all I
think a good book can definitely help
you open up a lot of opportunities but
it's not neat is that your cool there's
a lot of other ways it's not grants to
do it breaks book is really hard right
before me was a two-year process the
second book was coming along a little
bit faster so you have to really want
them doing if it's a succubus thing is
you have to deeply you're deeply
passionate you have a message that you
want to share this needs to come out
right you need to give birth to this
thing it's that important to you then
you should go on to do it if it's part
of your marketing strategy and a nice to
have then I think there's other more
effective ways you can to just want to
make sure that it's ready
in my business you're starting to
company forward important reasons not
just time to big money or just prove
something right so you have to really
really really really watch right blow if
you are the next extension of you tip
number two is created outlined in a
schedule what I found really helpful for
me was to create outline at the start so
when I spoke your one word we've got
seven chapters it's three sections and
so I start from the top
what's the big idea that I want to get a
cost and this works really well with
nonfiction but also the fiction what is
what are the main things and I'm trying
to get across and then how does that
break down so I have three main sections
of book okay what are those three things
look like and then within three then how
do I divide those into different
chapters greater pace or have these
traffic tear these chapters here great
all my texts now I can press and work on
individual chapters and in that chapter
what I want to talk about and go page by
page by page and so I find it really
hard to think big and think small the
same time so I see my big thinking works
that's the outlook that's full view but
we're trying to accomplish that's the
general breakdown of the section and
then once it's all planned out you can
just the headline or a title then
existent work why not just moving that
page and I trust that it's filled in
with everything else that I'm trying to
do business strategy photography really
well also if your goal is to get it in
to a publisher saying they want to see
an outline they want to know what you're
doing they want to see a single chapter
as well you'll submit cementum gets into
your writing style and I think to the
scheduling part created a schedule for
yourself to make time write a lot of
work for eventhough and so you need to
dedicate time in your schedule you know
I'm just going to have pockets that
magically open up and serving at least I
need to define dedicated time to do it
everybody has their own process
some people love writing to crappy pages
a day and they spend half an hour good
morning writing for me that didn't work
I needed to have chunks of time if I sat
down in the morning and tried to
fifteen a half an hour 15 minutes half
an hour of writing took me that long
just to get into the zone to Friday and
another stop there would be something
else I need to block out my whole day so
I was right under one word that was
Michael Tuesday so it's been the entire
Tuesdays right on the globe so walk get
out of my place I would walk to a local
coffee shop I would get your questions
and document the journey as I went along
and when I got to the coffee shop or the
shut out all distractions and just right
took me about thirty minutes to get into
the zone like okay now at the moment I
try to stay there as much as possible so
if it's really really important that it
gets done what is in your calendar it's
time for it again this is for everything
I'm just writing the book you have
prioritizes things are important to you
and put them in your calendar or they
won't get done if you just wait for some
time I sleep here Yorgi that's not going
to happen
schedule tip number three is decide
whether you want to self publish or use
a publisher really just depends on what
your goals are if your goal is primarily
financials you want to be able to make
money from it means you want to be able
to control a lot of the aspects of it
then self publishing this away so you
make all money with the kind of
commission from whatever go thing with
on realism each other and you decide
everything will cover all the words
inside everything every aspect about it
you need to have full control over
that's exactly your vision and it is out
there
that's solution model if your goal is to
have reach your goals you will use your
publishers brand name recognition
equals a publisher for me my role is to
help feeling entrepreneurs and so I want
it I always want to work on projects
that have the ability to have a massive
amount that's what I strive for every
single day and so self-publishing wasn't
the route that I wanted to go I wanted
to go with the major publishers because
I value not just their ability to help
them with the editing and all that
for that but distribution promotion
cover the brand name attached to it not
so much that adding penguin or binding
really means a lot but hang another book
can mean a lot and so I want to use
about the best change to have big reach
to get into bookstores to get name
recognition and so that's why I want to
the publisher things are going to go
with a publisher I highly recommend
trying to get a literary agent first
literary agent based in regulation like
real estate agent but for your book
insist for your house their job is to
know all the different people all the
different publishers where they have
money what books they're interested in
in create basically when I was doing
mine we had five calls with publishers
on two days back to back to back to back
to back to back and it created kind of
some drama right so we talked to RDO and
talking another talk about their and
making us increasing the commitment of
significantly from where we started and
so when you can create that kind of
anymore
it gets you more interested in you and
you need a well trained literary agent
on the connection to make that happen so
if you're going to go the publisher room
I recommend both literary agents they
usually take a percentage of your deals
but much much much more pays for itself
as well as the advice and positioning
comparatively try to do with my trip so
tip number four is to overcome rejection
our series on evans channel called
unlocking lily and one of the challenges
I have to research famous speakers and a
lot of them wrote books but what if the
authors that was really really resonated
with me is Jack Canfield the Jack
Canfield was rejected by a hundred and
forty four publishers before is able to
publish this old chicken suit with a
soul he imagined if he gave up after the
first delicious or human Odysseus one
for the 101 we wouldn't have access to
and his message with them is completely
lost so many millions of people actually
benefit book so that's a screening for
you anytime you're projected keep going
I don't know
no pretentious is hard especially if you
put your entire life's work and effort
into this book and it should get shut
down and rejected so browser Mohan you
need to keep going and going through all
the projections and overcome them
because it's important to you your
message needs to be out there and then
there's a funny old thing there's a lid
for every pot so every time you bring a
book to a publisher and they see notes
go to the next one go to the next one
keep going and you will find a list to
your top tip number five is habit text
audio this was actually something
surprises that's not really done in the
publishing world when I was getting
close to the draft of my first book
after one word I was getting ready to
get it out there and let people know
about it
I said okay so what do we do with tech
guys how do we get feedback on this and
they said well we don't we don't do test
audiences we don't get feedback and it's
something that's really common in a lot
of other industries you know in software
before you start selling your product
you said it as your beta testers and
they test to tell you what's wrong with
it and how can we fix in the movie
business they'll make the movie and have
test screenings and then they'll see
what the audience reaction is it may be
cheesy interchange different students
because they thought that was a people
laugh but it didn't last one switch it
up they got too scared at the end and
walked up let's switch that up in the
book business it's not really done
they're so concerned about people
getting early access and it you know
being shared to my
and you don't just it's just not part of
problem she works and is so incredibly
helpful to do such we do our thirty
copies of my fault got to thinking about
analysis wolf condo because of fun day
pain and has his mind in and I shift
them engages to people who were in my
local area somewhere on turns one half
monster of half more entrepreneurs to
the one with general perspective is the
feedback was helpful I just read my book
down to half I wrote two bucks so they
wanted 1665 thousand words in the book
and I wrote like a hundred and twenty
hundred thirty thousand words and half
the book is gone with cut based on the
feedback that came from my test body and
so I highly recommend that you print off
twenty to thirty two copies of your book
before those the final print and just
get to be done for people who are inside
your target market and outside just to
get gift suggestions and nasty about
grammar errors all that kind of stuff
but more like how does it residences did
you like this part in the thing I really
pay attention to the sessions work from
the nonfiction book was where people
underlined and is note that they've
opened results I didn't care what they
wrote wasn't really pay attention to how
it would be packing them but oh this is
page got a lot of people underlined and
Mike Wright is open the column and these
four pages nobody cared about we're easy
to decide which pages the cut for the
book will have a test hot tip number six
is get ready for pre-launch it's not
just about writing the great folks you
have to have marketing you need to
promote it that'll get exposure from it
it's really important and start thinking
easy way to do it is I couldn't start
documenting the process along the way so
I was watching the one word every week
I'd make a new video I would update you
guys with how it was going or was that
my concerns my victories and they'll get
to your questions when I process as well
and so things documenting your process
documents of your journey whether it's
on YouTube or Twitter or Instagram or
Facebook or wherever you live
let's build a little bit of a community
up and get people to join you on that
path so they are excited for the book
coming out they're ready to buy in
advance have services that relate to the
book and give an incentive provide early
and survive multiple I think one of the
biggest mistakes I made in my total
package was it didn't have a to auction
ticket by wonderful I think it was then
10 Lopes and then optically Myron up
from there but a lot of people
identifying one book in another book for
a friend
I didn't have a to look forward as an
option so do it again it would have
something for if you buy two books with
the easy entry point but not just
waiting for the logical everything goes
okay carefully planning the pre-launch
of it counting down on your website
showcasing kind of features of looking
to be in their doctrine is a process
that people can join one agree and
they're excited for you get a chance to
talk about your book over and over and
over and over again without it being
emotional because you're providing value
updating every second online assist the
presenters keep marketing just because
your book as Corrado doesn't mean just
that market it's not just about week one
when it just comes out it's constantly
marketing marketing marketing marketing
and hopefully your book ties into what
recurrence is doing whether you're a bug
leader whether you're an entrepreneur
whatever is it you're doing it will
hopefully kind of fills a void and kind
of part of your ongoing process and I
didn't you can involve it into things
that you do a couple of thousands of how
we do it one content so I'm a constantly
youtuber I have real Twitter another
account social media and I always have
consistent content on the book on my
snapchat Instagram Facebook and Twitter
it may just be reading the quote from
the book almost every week then I'll
read a book from the book and post out
of this book ten second video I use the
book in these the book is my videos
lined up right the book is always kind
of seen product placement in here I feel
my one word top of the video extent
people the in his videos bought the blog
gives up shut up I ask people to
remember with their members in the video
so it creating
content that includes the bus where else
I don't have a four-second situation
with doesn't work but sometimes the book
will be in the 7 ways but revive is
undoing words applicable to part of my
process and so creating content that
feels natural
the such as promotional content would
naturally face because this value in the
book that you created the second thing I
see is that is just really helpful work
that wealth of a half that haven't seen
a lot of other people do is every piece
my assistant will go to Amazon pull out
my book page and then see what related
books are recommended down below so it
might be a grip or don't help might be
Gary Vaynerchuk spoke buy from
comparators book whatever the most
relevant slope it is for my fault family
and then my cystic will then go to
youtube where I'm most known it has a
biggest following and start connecting
to other youtubers who have done book
reviews on those other books and shall
be chosen here she did a review of Gary
Vaynerchuk subjunctive Jeff read books
or his new book I just emailed I have a
book opportunity for you here's Kevin
he's got a book called your one word
it's really related to what Gary's doing
I think you'll enjoy and if you want
every to be a part of your video let me
know and so I'm often either reading the
view to the ball or providing a
voiceover for the books depends on how
they do their videos and so that's been
a highly effective way with subline and
around 40 or 50 youtubers propel my
books just by others to preach on
related books and the third thing we do
around market is really following up to
the readers you know a lot of readers
don't your recent book anything but most
people who'll buy your book you will
just sit on the Shelf will never read it
just collect dust and that I would much
rather sell 10 books everybody reads
those technical reads a book from some
100 and nobody reads right and so having
a way to followup with readers and
making sure that they're consuming the
content that needed help
we do a lot of work so one of the things
that we tried to do in the three
campaigns collect email I wish it is
something stronger in the book one of my
regrets is
I wish like on the first page it says
email your originality receipt to this
email address of incentive bonuses
because that way you can collect a lot
more email addresses most of the people
who bought my blog where to Amazon I
don't know who they are so I hope we
have following up with them this
frustrating but we did collect a lot of
email addresses from our readers and
they get for the particular where every
month I'm sending them an email that's
related to the book that asking how
they're doing just checking if you find
your one worth can I help and maybe your
resource to have any questions or any
problems I also send them a video
Samantha's answering something this
question so it's an unlisted video that
you don't have access to it lets you
possible and you get that once a month
and it'll also make a customized video
for everybody in just a quick 10 second
video hey John thank you so much pick up
my book I see you from California I
really appreciate Department and I was
just in California you know last month
if I come back again geez great really
connect to do something together
what's up Jonathan Alexandra happy
Tuesday what's up man greetings from
Toronto all the way out to Jamaica this
is a quick personal videos and people
really appreciate it
so my goal of the follow up because some
people never pick up the book and read
it or some people like after the third
message they read it in fact as they say
feel people to the vitamin book yet you
want the people who read your book to
spray like weird about this is so
important for an awkward trying to get
that book out is young yes many money
with Superbowl commercials right so with
million dollar ad campaign so you want
this people to spread for you when they
haven't read the clause and they can't
spread the message and so thinking about
ways to collect people's email addresses
put it in a book give them bonuses I
also try to the focus you be having any
problems times one word feed on me as a
email address in there so people connect
to that method as well is if you can get
them finding value in the bulk that much
more likely to tell their prices so
those it really is that I'm using for
myself
birthday night routine to find ways in
teams to market is not just a one-off
big lunch date
so those are my seven tips on how to
write a book for beginners I made this
video because n sub trouble aptitude so
if you want me to cover a topic in a
future second way video there's a link
in the description you can go check it
out there and vote for your next paper
topic
I don't smoke in a way to make this
video what was your favorite tipple was
multiple people to your process and your
size and as I've missed it you want to
ask the list please share down comes
below I really couldn't see what you
have to say I also wanted to give a
quick charter to the legendary Brian
Tracy bright making so much bigoted cop
I suppose dear ones word and share your
review and posting to Twitter really
means loves me and I'm so glad you
enjoyed the book so thank you guys for
watching I believe in you I hope you
need to believe in yourself and whatever
your one where it is much love